turning now to the impeachment inquiry
we have new information about the White
House decision to hold up hundreds of
millions of dollars in US military aid
to Ukraine senior Trump administration
officials tell CBS News an internal
review uncovered emails showing acting
White House chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
asking for legal justification for the
freeze after the fact and Tracy is that
the White House been what's the
significance of these emails
well these emails are servicing just as
Democrats are getting close to forming
articles of impeachment against
President Trump and they may provide new
evidence now according to the Washington
Post which first reported these emails
the exchanges began after President
Trump ordered the hold on military aid
to Ukraine and after his July 25th call
with ukrainian President zalenski
in which he asked Solinsky to
investigate Joann hunter Biden now in
early August acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney asked the Office of Management
and Budget for legal justification for
withholding the aide and how much longer
it could be delayed at the White House
podium in October Mulvaney notably
admitted an investigation into the 2016
election and Ukrainian corruption were
two of the reasons the aide was held up
in a statement the Office of Management
and Budget stood by its strategy writing
there was a legal consensus at every
step of the way that the money could be
withheld in order to conduct the policy
review now that aid was eventually
released to Ukraine on September 11th
that's two days after Congress found out
about the whistleblower complaint that
sparked the impeachment inquiry
we're also learning that the House
Intelligence Committee has obtained new
information about a key figure tied to
Rudy Giuliani that's right so CBS News
has learned that the committee
reportedly now has audio and video
recordings as well as photographs from
Giuliani associate Lev Parnas now Parnas
has pled not guilty to campaign finance
charges the congressional committee
subpoenaed him last month for
information tying him to Rudy Giuliani
and president Trump Parnas is a business
associate of Giuliani's he played a key
role in efforts to launch a Ukrainian
corruption investigation against Joanne
hunter Biden and sources tell us that
Parnas won
to tell his story and he will comply as
necessary now over the weekend Rudy
Giuliani said that he has an insurance
policy if President Trump were to throw
him under the bus he later clarified
that what he meant by insurance was
actually dirt on the Biden's jurika
alright Ben Tracy for us thank you